hello what up how's it going I hope
you're having a wonderful twos Wednesday
it's Wednesday I totally knew what day
it was ah but that doesn't matter
because we're here to play Resident Evil
4 on the Nintendo switch I'm very
excited to see how this performs yeah
I'm excited too I've played a few
Resident Evil games 1 5 & 6 so I
actually have not played this one so I'm
excited and then was telling me there's
like an adaptive like AI like so it's
gonna adapt to how good or bad idea
so yeah it's got a pretty good AI setup
in it and it'll it'll be I'm interested
to see your your because your first time
playing it seeing how you react to a lot
of the stuff that goes on it's
definitely one of the best Resident Evil
games and now we can take it everywhere
so I'm just gonna switch it over to the
gameplay cuz we don't want to see us
anymore we want to see this video game
boom
pressed a save that it does not exist
hello welcome thank you guys for
sticking with us here there it is you
know it's a good Resident Evil time when
you hear the announcer say the name of
the game we get this cool back they'll
forget it I'll never forget it it was
the year when those grisly murders
occurred in the our claim mountains soon
after the news was out to the whole
world revealing that it was the fault of
a secret viral experiment conducted by
the international pharmaceutical
enterprise
the virus broke out in it for such a
great game this intro is kind of kind of
a weird thing this originally come out
was it in their own idea it was was like
the original not not for ya but I love
this game too Denise this dream is gonna
decide whether or not I buy another copy
of residue before and I already own like
two copies on the PC I owned it on the
game if you had a wee copy I didn't play
too much bought again on the 360
it's my B's might be switch time you can
play a game for the first time and host
something specifically and this one just
came out yesterday on switch with
Resident Evil 1 oh this looks like it's
60fps that's already making me real
excited who are you anyway Leon Scott
Kennedy guess that's a locals way of
breaking the ice anyway you know what
this is all about
well you see here's to search for the
president's missing daughter
[Music]
do you know who I am that is one of the
the strongest points I think about
Leon's character and how he develops is
how he goes from resonable to to him in
this game where he's gone from like the
oh no it was my first day on the job and
a zombie outbreak happened - he's the
only person who's like shoot the zombie
in the head we know how to deal with
this which it's really refreshing to
have someone who's like I know how to
deal with this problem I believe it's
digital I haven't seen a physically
straight edge be like Leon Scott Kennedy
keep your same haircut from 1998 Oh Oh
No
what could it be yeah yeah definitely
CME's sorry to remake treatment I'd like
to see it but I don't know if it needs
it as bad as re2 did I'm very very
excited to see resident evil 3 if that
ever happens so what was your favorite
one of all of them
for me personally it's a toss-up between
the remake of one and three and four so
I I the three is the one that I've
probably got to defend the most cuz
people like oh yeah remakes really good
and four is really good but a lot of
people look at three is not great but it
was the one that messed me up the most
like as a kid so I'll never forget it I
think the time in your life that you've
played something to also plays a big
factor
parking yeah the so I think the main
thing that got me was for two games so I
played the original release my dad
played it and then I played it then I
played two and then I played three is
all throughout the whole the first two
games
it sets up this whole like zombies can't
chase you through doors and then make a
giant 8-foot tall zombie with a rocket
launcher that can chase you through
doors the daughter of the president Leon
or the right girl because it's the
president's daughter yeah this is this
is this is performing much better than I
thought it would it's got the motion
blur on it which is cool but it's I'm
pretty sure at 60fps and this is
obviously docked because we're streaming
it but if you need to go for it so you
don't actually look with the right stick
and kind of look and pivot with that
until you press L and you pull up your
gun then you you can aim with yeah it's
it's like have you tried a hundred
percent this game yet I have not crime I
put a considerable amount of time into
the HD remake but I haven't tried 200%
also I don't know if anyone else knows
this haven't got a chance to look up
much about it but is this the HD version
like with all the extra stuff that's in
the HD version or is this like just
residue before up res oh my gosh the
habit to just like use my right analog
the roundest yes it's a bit weird dude
that is an excellent question Clifford's
accuse me it's all man I wonder if you
can actually play this with a GameCube
controller there wasn't the question
that Clifford was asking but because you
can hook your GameCube controller up and
it works with the menu and a whole bunch
of other games if I was wife I could
play Resident before with the game too
crucial or gonna be worth the price of
admission alone ready to fight freeze
I'm pretty sure he's not gonna listen to
you get down
and for the head oh my god is so fast
okay sorry sorry you can even adjust
that the sensitivity probably couldn't
I've been playing too many different
consoles alright must be pushing against
it it's like a port of the HD console
version four states praise are
rectangular ah there we go see that
that's the the small detail that I'm
kind of looking for got some more ammo
oh and Gabe explained already figured
out you can't play with the GameCube
controllers shoot it looks like I'm
picking up res Leo 4 on the switch
tonight ample times oh my god is that a
runny egg no so anyway that's the first
enemy in Resident Evil 4 I'm excited to
see how the rest of this is gonna go
[Applause]
better for combat you never have to use
the camera button yeah but basically you
shouldn't even be using the the right
stick at all outside of the area that
quick sir playing with the controller
it's making me very excited you jump out
that window behind you get that action
shot there are a bunch of dudes down
there so I know I like I was like oh
yeah I jump out the window but I totally
didn't tell you what you're jumping into
so you press back and run you can you
can do like a 180 that's a very useful
maneuver also the big thing about
reservoir 4 is that it has
location-based damage so you shoot a guy
in the leg he'll like fall over or you
shoot a guy in the head also if you
stagger them like that you can do melee
attacks on them which is my favorite
thing so aim and then a like 'man run I
think is what should reload there you go
reload right there like that scheme is
my favorite resident be it like 5 times
or so dude sly this game is fantastic
and it still holds up and I'm really
excited that it it's on a portable
console and it runs there's a little bit
of frame drop there but for the most
part it seems like it's been running
very afraid
[Music]
nothing no problem hmm they want to go
down there the boys I keep using this
stupid right analog I'm not gonna touch
wofford also calling out the the
inevitable village fight that you're
gonna get into here coming up it's gonna
be don't don't feel bad if if you get
got he's ready for it where ya stand
standstill
I'm trying so hard to move it slightly
and I can do it
there yeah perfect
why is $30 it's kind of yeah it's weird
that it's $30 here when it's $20
everywhere else I guess they're
expecting us to play it like pay for the
price of convenience it's a bit foolish
Wow he dodged she saw that I wasn't even
gonna shoot yet
you got this I believe in you I I'm
trying really go bond you can do it
you good oh I'm trying there there we go
like how he staggered like that if you
run up on him you could do a melee at
that time oh yeah it's just a regular
button press like you don't have to pull
out the knife at all like it's it's like
a like an animated like you karate kick
the guy or something like that jump the
bridge no I think the only thing you do
is sprint out of the way if if you get
got we could pass the controller around
whatever you feel like
I'm down we ready to mess with the
sensitivity if you wanna this might be
the there you go mmm I don't know if
that's in there what are the video
settings out of curiosity its adjust
brightness oh we can turn the motion
blur off
I'll try turning it off actually
something I think it'll that might
actually do something
juicebox is recommending going for the
legs I I'm a big fan of shooting the
legs out yes I don't think I can change
I guess yeah I don't think you can
change it but though that is a good
button layout it's a skip movies oh this
looks that's more more more motion
blurry that's not how that works at all
oh there we go must have turned it on
alright alright nailed it nice the music
stopped that's a good sign
knock on the porch and check the house
you might be able to find some stuff to
heal with possibly if you double tap the
button you can kick the door down
that's just books yep
Oh apparently they're also some settings
only available in the main menu not not
entirely sure if that's where the
sensitivity is but crimes giving us a
shout-out for that he's not a zombie
he's calling it out so we do have a
first-aid spray but I don't know if I'd
use it just yet first aid sprays are
real clutch it's possible maybe oh there
you go so you pull out your knife and
you break that box you got some money
which isn't good for health but it's
good for money they say money can buy
happiness well grant I can't buy the
health either
there you go there should be stuff up in
this house though - whatever works
more money give me your money all right
hit a quicksave just to do it some
people are already jumping on the next
part there's a dog you're about to walk
up into I don't know if you've heard
them crying I I personally hope you
saved the dog that's kind of where I am
he's not having a good time he's out of
here
you might see that dog again later on
also that's your heads up to look out
for bear traps
[Music]
yeah there are also a few traps between
trees and stuff look out for also
another good show from Jordan who's
saying you can shoot the birds if you
want extra items and get like eggs and
more money because birds have money on
the MCUs
that's so scary that the reload is like
he completely stops moving in everything
you can't move yo weights that's not
that classic resident evil though you
got it you can't move when you shoot
it's too much to do you can't move when
you reload I the infinite rocket
launcher and the Matilda also great
Matilda for life I'm a big fan of that
Chicago typewriter though just because
if you got the right outfit on you get
to do that really cool reload animation
and that's just the kind of edgy teen I
was so I've been trying to keep a real
close eye on the frame rate and it it
seems to be like I'm still like 97 98
percent of the time at 60 frames and
then it hitches maybe a little bit
sometimes but not very often
so you're opening you punching it you'd
do that too I guess
not what I was going for play oh
definitely works Oh super precedent just
pressed about me was it's only when I
when they do like the recoiling for it
all the red nine though we get all the
attachments for it and everything so
good birds like shiny things that's true
Bob Jones I can't argue that
so the 45 or 45 to 50 that you guys
might be seeing might be YouTube's doing
its thing but like watching it being
displayed on our monitor it it
definitely is it's 60 a lot of the time
missed those dips those those random
dips that are really throwing me off
it's like right there I saw one when we
were like moving our our aim around
Purell a lot of really good weapons and
Resident Evil 4 well so they still got
like scary stuff that happens sometimes
you know what Jonathan we're getting our
hunt on so he's he's still alive when
they do fall down though that is a
really good time to pull out the knife
and kinda just slash at him a bit but
you're doing some some dangerous
maneuvers yes so this is docked because
we don't have a way to capture if it's
on docked but that's what we're looking
at right now I heard that it might run
better even though when it's undock cuz
it's not trying to upscale it more than
it should be but I haven't tried it
personally so I got is the village is
gonna be time I hope you ready oh you
can't get the eggs from crows it's only
from chickens it's yeah YouTube says
Resident Evil Revelations better that's
a hot take I like Revelations I don't
know if I like Revelations as much as I
like resonate before though I like oh
here we go
yeah that's the stuff I like that's what
I'm here for okay
they're like you need to review this
before you go in here couple times just
so you know oh boy ready for some head
sawing action oh it wouldn't be rushing
before we didn't have any of that like
this is such a just go in there guns
blazing oh here's a do some sneaky work
yeah like like crime says Jonathan I
think this is just the HD version that's
been around for a bit does everybody
gotta go even the women Oh looks like
soup's on I'm ready for it
so I feel like this is probably going to
be one of the better places to test the
performance because I feel like it would
probably it's very strong so you can
shoot those out of the air if you want
to attempt it just so you know it's the
thing you can't do so a good time to
tell you there is a shotgun near the
church nice let's go to church I need
Jesus and also
is the situation at our I mean you can't
catch the people as they try to climb up
and get to you which is a strat some
shotgun shells controller types who the
one that switches how the the triggers
and bumpers work think it's back behind
you because the controller type two is
the one that switches how the bumpers
and triggers work I think that might be
the one that I am also a bigger fan of
it's that one right there
all right about the building to the left
yeah sorry I read that wrong
Oh Lord move that dresser oh my god
they're too resourceful the same Leon so
you can move that thing over that window
if you want so they'll have a harder
time coming in why do I hear like a
tiger that's a lady trying to come into
the window aim and then a should be the
wrong button Oh chain saws here we're
coming up the stairs I move forward I'd
run forward I'd gather where you are
that's real dangerous yeah yeah yo push
might jump out there you go oh yeah I
feel better about this all right oh my
god this guy with the chainsaw I wish it
would just
nice okay okay okay
the chainsaw noise hasn't gotten any
less scary over the years either he's
definitely not that though I don't know
if you want to waste your ammo he's a
very strong boy see I'm still seeing a
couple of frame hitches every now and
then but it's nothing too bad
got to round them up a little bit why is
he so much faster than everybody else
it's got a run with that chainsaw time
for church everybody's got to stop what
they're doing go to church hey I made it
through the village so it's all downhill
from here
Elwin I want to switch weapons oh okay
noted do I recommend it right now there
are tons of other places to play this
game if you want it to run well and have
more options like I'd say the PC version
of the HD version is probably the best
but for this being a portable thing this
is pretty rad they all went in there
it's so hard to just look at something
I need to leave at the town
she gave me an objective buddy in here
what'd she say you guys yeah this is an
official port done done by like Capcom
I'm fairly certain to the switch I don't
know what it would be not not official
port the idea of having this game just
anywhere it's really rad to me in fact
you can play with a GameCube controller
[Music]
that's also a very strong thing that's
swaying me towards picking it up
[Music]
standing in there all right there we go
we made it sir emblems you can find that
are hidden everywhere there's one right
there if you want to shoot it but it's
that green flashing thing I think you
still have to go into the menu to do it
well actually let me look at my button
configuration again because when I was
trying to run up at melee with why it
wasn't working so well it's only at
certain times like you can't do it all
the time it's they have to be recoiling
like hard after being shot in one of
their limbs yeah and you don't you don't
pull out the knife to do it I don't want
to waste my ammo on that oh I was like
it's a shotgun I'll still spray far
enough and we have alerted the town
what woman you know you turn changing
your controls to the type - and see
what's up with that or unless you have
to that's one of those options you have
to be out out of the menu for I think
separate ways was the the ADA game-mode
right Oscar
type 2 is got be on Ron what does it
change go back to one really quick go
back oh yeah yeah you definitely want
that because it's all on one stick you
don't even have to touch the right and
also a good call using the
nine-millimeter to shoot those yeah
those targets is probably a better call
a little better oh come on he's like so
naturally she feels like no it's also
not like a super important thing you
have to worry about no we're not doing
like a a whole playthrough so we it's
alright if we miss some of the secrets
and stuff like there's a thing next to
you that you can you can do nail just
like hard recoil check the freaking axe
at me
yeah I wouldn't guess I was talking
about the dependent that we walked past
but that's fine
wasn't no the well that was to the left
of you when you came in so there's a
little bit of a puzzle to it yeah I
thought you'd that's not the puzzle
that's I mean I mean that's it could
have been not proven not dirty but eight
whatever works
you got it so the way you're supposed to
is if you do it you you shoot out the
leg and then it closes and it's all good
I don't want to like spoil it for you I
I like that you did a full dodge for
that that's that's fantastic he's got
him in his back pocket
there yes yes that's a yeah yes fair
we've gone 203 no if you need Type three
[Music]
I feel like a lot of people kind of did
that to look Oh necklace sweet he's not
that bad
Leon's got very strong legs but not that
strong another man over there he's just
working he's just working
he was just baling hay and now he's dead
turn like what there we go you gotta
watch him disintegrate real quick I feel
yo Skyy I mean I've played this game a
lot too and it's I think I don't want to
like spoil the experience for someone's
playing it the first time so I wanna
like oh yeah to get the pay you just
gotta shoot the leg out of the thing
first
of course okay I kind of like letting
people discover it on their own but I
feel ya think I was also just bailing
Hey
so you shoot them and they're shooting
them in the legs is like the the best
easiest way cuz they'll also fall down
and then you can run up and knife them
if you want to
oh my gosh uh but yeah yeah I originally
when you were like oh it's a puzzle in
my mind I was thinking for some reason
like it would activate you know newer
games be like okay you gotta do this
puzzle but then I was like oh not that
literal
so organic puzzle control tips are
always good like in ladder suit beyond
me just in case
alright let's see I don't want to look
at those fools what they're gonna drop a
boulder on me Oh
oh my god run faster always gets
everyone is the fact that Li switch up
the buttons halfway through it because
you think you're tapping and you'll be
fine I hit yeah feels bad man okay cuz
now you're gonna be ready for it yeah
this game is really good at
checkpointing too which is nice
alright the button mix-ups are even more
hilarious
cuz I started with the eggs that's why
I'm yeah yeah like oh that was the very
last part - of course we did save the
dog at the beginning so we did get that
oh by the way here's another one here
turn around do a quick 180 real quick
look up see those The Shining things
shoot them out of the ceiling
you get money
[Music]
sometimes it's to point out some things
but yeah
come on Leon you got ice in your veins
why are you so JT bro oh there we go
she's Leon
frame images are probably the check
points that might be it some of them are
kind of like in the in the middle yeah
possibly well I'm like I'm saying it's
like a look at like a 97 98 percent of
the time it's got what seems to be 60fps
going
that's just my eyes though don't you
don't want to there's also a person who
throws dynamite the bear trap sir the
dynamite is there's a lot to deal with
all at once
yeah the movement isn't exactly
intuitive so I'm like yeah for me too I
I could start embarrassing myself on
this because it's been a while since
I've played
oh no the boulders fine it's you
checkpoint it after that it's like 60
variable yeah yeah it's it's not bad
though like it this is entirely playable
I just the other hang-up I have is the
fact that it's $10 more than all the
other versions
[Music]
so you can also shoot the dynamite out
of their hands while they're holding
okay wait let me sit ocean that's the
other thing when I aim down it doesn't
snap to where I would like for it to
snap okay some space you'd be a dude
like next to you that you just ran past
and one in the house and then one down
the other way like down over over that
way unless they've all gone inside the
house so think they might have all gone
inside the house
guess it's better than their mom oh no I
thought I heard dynamite there's a crate
over here no they are just hanging out
they're just having a good time what
you'd use the the nine-millimeter and
just pick off the dynamite while they're
holding it up in their hands yeah
they're in a prime position for it this
is perfect it seems like there isn't a
sensitivity option unless it's like out
on the menu and not in here but we
couldn't find it if you get too close
though they'll throw them and that'll
yeah there it is that's early there's
still someone else glitch down here in
here and walking through the wall
a better job or even somewhere there are
few bear traps
yes a thing that before I I took any
Spanish classes not knowing what these
guys were saying to then learning what
they were saying they're literally
saying like behind you it when they're
behind you and stuff and it's kind of
funny
I respect he still tried to kick it
anyway you might be able to shoot it off
now that sense is everything is a deal
never been a sensitivity option there
you go but definitely save it's been a
while so gun so far and died like twice
let's not see bad someone is walking
directly into the wall well that's the
way out oh we go through the only way
out is through okay
I mean yeah you can cut it too but like
what's more badass than shooting our oh
no not that did shooting up the lock on
the door everyone was upset because I
didn't suggest you cut the lock I
suggested that you shot it I mean you
can probably cut that I wouldn't though
because it's explosive you have the
merchant
[Music]
I have to look around like this because
the other way we're starting to give me
emotion see okay let's check out this oh
I see that's what's the noise what yeah
it's Johnny Depp that doesn't look like
the president's daughter you well though
the water you're buying aureus Ellen's
definitely good lines room but my
favorite I think is the body AHA ting
elephant stranger when you buy like a
really big gun or the quote was
something like that oh that's the big
cheese I said it at the same time I love
that Leon just tries to karate kick that
massive man end of chapter Horatio 81%
considering how bad I was struggling to
aim that's not that's not the best so
you took the shots when you knew that's
the difference all right
we're probably gonna struggle against
the cheese oh you don't have to fight
him for a while he's just gonna just
going to do some things and then
disappear for a bit
[Music]
does the cheese turn engine emesis no I
was like that shouldn't so this is uh
this is a completely different virus
from the other two that have happened
already this is called las Plagas and I
could totally nerd out on resident evil
for a bit but I'm gonna save everyone
the hassle you want to tell me what's
going on here right too much small talk
Johnny Depp name is Leon came here
looking for this girl
seen her
I mean crimes like don't worry no no
maybe few okay let me guess she's the
president's daughter ting yes
johnny-on-the-spot
now we know where we got to go he looks
like he's had a rough time I used to be
a cop in Madrid both cops why'd you quit
nobody really appreciates you enough for
it being a hero isn't what it's cracked
up there'll be anymore
used to be a cop myself only for a day
though I thought I was bad only he had
the worst first day ever that's the one
Oh Mary we're tied up
and this guy now turn the game volume I
got you a kick a man into a wall so hard
you break his neck on the way down Leon
has he's also lost his jacket it's hot
again this is snake I've infiltrated the
base what happened he managed to escape
on the location of that church no but
apparently there's a secret passage in
the village it leads there
oh boy back to the village old boy so
you're gonna get to meet the one of the
best characters in Roseau for strange ah
one of the best he's the guy who sells
you guns rifle ammo so I think the thing
is you're supposed to buy the rifle from
him but
yeah the guy we just saw in the window
but we're gonna see where this guy was
going first got something that might
interest you all the classic judge card
selection got a selection of good things
on sale stranger I need to shoot 10 to
get the special gun what are you boy in
so smart move
that's hash a case so you have more room
to like put things in your inventory but
also the rifle pretty handy don't know
how it's gonna work out with that
sensitivity stuff going on it's it's
really useful is that old strange yes
now you've got to find a way to fit it
into your inventory you might have to
move the shotgun around to the side move
the egg down we just put it in there to
whatever works true definitely don't
shoot the merchant you can also spend
money on upgrades for your guns like you
can increase your magazine capacity for
the pistol you're using now it's very
useful welcome
/ zobar thank you stay in this corner
with this random flame you have next to
you it makes it easy to find him the TMP
is good too I don't know I've always
been more of a fan of actually just
going with the rifle especially for this
next part as you can pick off a lot of
dudes from far away if you need to also
this this part I remember dying on a few
times myself cuz it was just kind of a
thing to deal with it's a lot of
vertical fighting that you can do here
there's also guys I think right
oh and then it glows okay 180 oh my gosh
I wish you would
there you go rifles good they're all
definitely heading your way right now
yep there you go this is the reticle
doesn't snap back too
she get that reload if you can order
still on their way see there are some
definite FPS drops happening right now
[Music]
summer oh wait
okay
oh my gosh I don't know if it has
penetration yeah I remember that being a
big thing
so you've only got three shots
[Music]
and your shotguns very useful for this
what up Paul how's it going hope you're
having a good day
bringing me all the money
[Music]
that is also a good shout that I totally
forgot about if you take too long to
loot things will actually disappear so
it's good to move up whole gangs here I
know y'all are bacon yeah
you're dynamite I don't like it okay
okay I need that
I need
so first dates parade that it does a lot
but I don't know if you need to use it
just yet
you probably be fine with the green
urban the so that that increases your
maximum health if you take that and then
use the agony
I met that out pretty close nice I was
like we are out of fatty ammunition so
these guys aren't zombies they've got a
different virus in them that just kind
of like enhances their abilities so
there's still cognizant and smart and
they can kind of like work together and
communicate but it's not like that like
a tier of G virus that turns them
oh no oh no that's bad
whenever you aim down it like I'm trying
to like so think of you holding down it
it stays so enough like you were you're
letting go of it well it's like when I
try to down here it automatically snaps
to straight ahead and then I pull it
down like think I think like if you if
you hold it like keep holding the button
down even through like a reload it
should pop back up where it was
times are getting tough oh and there's
dude up there and he looks like he's
busted awesome
they all draw money on be nice they drop
something yeah but they all have pitch
breaks
can I blow that up yes this is his first
time playing resting before checking out
on the switch there you go I enjoyed
five for what it was there's a fun co-op
game
I feel bad though because shovel is a
really cool character that I feel like
we're never gonna see again
I don't know if I'd nice them
[Music]
so what we're gonna do is get this first
spray popping right now oh wow you have
no ammo and I got oh boy yeah you're
getting those calls for clutch plays
Jonathan believes you can make it happen
you have to rock and do the the knife
stuff Oh God so that does have the
penetration right off the bat
[Music]
I agree Carlo I think he definitely
should play through through this game if
you've got the time all the way it's
very good all right knife time
kick a kick yeah all right now get over
him and knife him again yeah yeah yeah
yeah got it we've got some
okay
- blink right now see everyone's getting
their giggles out because I said
penetration my god you can zoom in with
the right stick like push hard there you
go it's gonna make it easier why does it
say right stick on the UI that's silly
yeah everything's like a little backward
oh that's probably just for the aiming
so long this game is yeah there's a lot
to it yeah one bullet
[Music]
oh yeah so you you are looking for
puzzle pieces for the door that you are
masters
there are so many guys
[Music]
I might jump down any move away from
there before they get here shotgun
shells that's good
[Music]
I know there was a mercenaries mode in
this game outlet that's included in this
one I'm pretty sure the mercenaries what
was it I played Rosina for so many times
now I just don't remember well there is
a mercenary
[Music]
[Music]
one more bullet and also someone sneezes
on you runs good tie got tossed there's
a lot of guys yes join me to give it a
shot me see what see what I can do all
right um let's see where we are
okay we got this maps there that's there
all right yeah rest in peace Leon I
failed you
yeah my adaptive difficulty is selection
yeah I am actually
satisfied that I don't nobody the
one-handed body slam my I'd sell some
things don't think this is gonna be
better
oh yeah I forgot we picked that up it
would have been worth more if it wasn't
dirty no I guess it's fine
all right that's their I might need to
actually go into the that's the novel
but I wanted to use thanks Jason I
appreciate the encouragement he said
actually a pretty good for your first
time
yeah it is just awkward controls I'm not
really used to like I'm gonna end up
like overwatch and stuff so and apex
right like you have to look directly at
the item to pick it up like oh I can't
just like walk over and somebody I
smoked gotcha
[Music]
right little good to see Diane like one
shot
[Music]
yeah ran in there
there was nobody
or a lot of people inside of that room
yikes all you if that blue all of them
up I'm really here hell yeah
running around like a chicken with my
head cut off that sweet chick music
girls like
oh boy oh boy
Oh
[Music]
come on there we go whoo
see you old man how many times we have
to teach you this lesson old man
[Music]
hello
I hear you but I don't see you
[Music]
it's so satisfying so morbid
it's a good setup like it's it's very
true Jose is you have dynamiter it was
taking that that shot see if you take
out his pals some of them that was the
real tech there we go
Oh
yeah I definitely leave them up there
[Music]
right here are you guys
oh hi
we're good we're fine this is okay
get that double pizza Chesky yes it's
got a breeze it out for a second and
then this bridge should be an excellent
place thought I can wait it out you're
still here
all right
oh I thought I could get out of the air
[Music]
the music is poor users just hanging out
great he was like the nicest of them
Jimmy says try to shoot the dynamite we
tried well I got the one but you got the
one dynamite or we took out like seven
dudes that was a pretty good time this
music is still going though and I'm
wondering if it's just people like up on
the side Sanders bins red will make the
adaptive difficulty rise and then that's
the plan
what Ben did to your home there we go
I'm glad that I'm still got like some of
my resident 4 abilities like it's kind
of latent sitting there I kind of got it
yeah
got the right hat oh he's sky over there
[Music]
see you
the riffle though that's fine that's
fine where we're going we don't need
rifles we've got the best best gun in
our inventory
I'm half expecting to like jump down and
see a guy down the music
hello oh there he is
it's kind of chilling off the side it's
like these last few stragglers
pistol ammo
my dude just died though you don't know
that that's suit vest yeah yeah that's
some supreme you're like dude save him
oh no we got to catch these bodies
alright forget it do it I don't feel
like I'm doing an all right job
conserving what I got
there's a lot of a lot of dudes that
needed to be dead there also i re4 is
not too bad with that do we have to like
look at this first or do I do have to
combine it probably right yep hey you
want to you want take over again
alright was we're we're not done
streaming yet today neither are we
coming back and playing sonic on Twitter
yeah team sonic racing later you guys
via a Twitter only stream but uh it'll
be a good time hope you'll be there
what's the I didn't want to do that at
all because I wanted to press that
button in that button cuz you could just
combine it and now I've botched it
because I don't know where the buttons
are anymore
all right supposed to shoot a thing to
get that
remember oh yeah there we go
and don't shoot that one well time
should be in how long from now
so like I've barely missed me
Oh touch you out of the air
[Music]
you bowled over
yeah that was men
meantime
Oh
No
yeah there you go Rosie before is a good
game I wouldn't have the sheer power
my roundhouse kicking them in the head
cinsay there are a bunch of dynamite
boys on the other side of this I
remember that
were you have
so let those guys come over here yeah
there it is
we can't Oh the trap I think I can knife
them well here dudes this is dangerous
thing get my money
[Music]
I hear you guys but I don't see you guys
lay down take it now
I saw that coming from a mile away
any mission
there we go now I can make up for my
botch that I said earlier boom boom yeah
this looks much better to watch your
media is my like reticles like all over
the place
there
also played this game didn't have
anything for me
it's that adaptive difficulty they like
you're too good you don't believe this
but I do I need all the things and all
of the ammo and all the guns you see
over there you're mine now
oh my god it's too big to fit like
inventory we need to take this weird
attache case this man has what's you got
like a military-grade sniper rifle in
there nine-millimeter pistol and a
largemouth bass let's go along Leon
what's deal Clell says I remember how
blown away everyone was when this game
released yeah I mean if you considered
some of the older games around the same
time I have expected a snake to be in
there this is a fun thing I like to do
is I like to put snakes inside the boxes
I have to actually shoot it don't I
that's fine I don't need that I don't
need that these guys though the bird had
money on it weird things have happened
atomic Fran said they should have
updated the herbs to be CBD for this
2019 version yeah like old games with
modern current like present-day
adaptation yeah yeah that would be like
for all games it's a large crystal ball
which way do this is the fun thing where
I get to try to solve puzzles I haven't
done it yet bringing around the one
thing I never commit to memory and
Resident Evil is the puzzle solutions
that way it's fresh every time I do it
definitely not because I'm not smart I
look at these keys I'll look at these
papers sure was a good note see what
shoot we're actually sort of in the the
last 10 minutes of this if we want to
keep it an hour hour and a half
us the cheese man Mayor McCheese is here
and he's not happy about it
[Music]
if you become I think you're right Carlo
not ready for it but we'll see what
happens so we actually didn't get to
fight the Big Cheese not yet you know he
keeps popping up a bit eventually you
will but see I'm still more on the
defensive like he's just a really old
retired Gorton's fisherman like that's
that's where I've always been
tell me fill me in below the moon
monado's that's a mouthful
Leon only rolls one way and it's with
short words Leon loves brevity I don't
think we have the ADA chapter unlocks we
haven't played through it yet all the
way because I think it happens after
that anyway they're more important I
didn't see a thing on the main menu for
it Leon oh boy open grab it eat it
delicious
[Music]
I don't I don't know why I keep thinking
that the inventory should be on why I
don't know what game I was playing or
where that came from it it's up oh gosh
it's got a very big foot Dave is really
really something else in this game first
playthrough there you go save him she
never waits up no matter how many times
Leone asks I guess so say there's a
dinner table down here and everyone's
invited to hang out but no one showed up
we're dinner guests let's see how far
how far can we get in six minutes oh
it's definitely a chainsaw person here
yike I'm out of hearing
I'll see you later
yeah I see you down there you don't need
to yell
are you a critical hit was just what I
needed
Erick's can leave chainsaw oil
come through today give him that a half
a second wait in America on Jay yeah the
pump fake
try to get up here now do it I dare you
No
waiting for someone to come out behind
me yep there it is I was like it's been
only too long of a time for this to be
okay yeah there's multiple ways up let's
use this one get that health improvement
this dang village I can't just like walk
right up in here yeah oh no I have the
key forget about it
I got a mess with that we're trying to
speedrun this out we only got four
minutes left
yeah you know it hit it the dank is the
dungeons where all the superior herbs
are
course of course adaptive difficult
we've got some good things on sale
strange on our way here grades some
things I can't get that rocket launcher
though you know we're gonna do is just
because it's easiest thank you yeah I
think that also refreshes our our ammo
count in our pistol too which is also
big clutch thing so move on forward with
this think I'm going forward
awesome going backwards gonna be real
weird I could have sold the fish what am
I thinking these last three minutes of
the stream definitely no I think we
obviously I think Leon's a type of guy
who wouldn't sell that fish I think
Leon's the type of guy who would eat
that fish she just eat it
you know maybe we should just fight the
the guy - I'm gonna sit here and I'm
gonna go to my inventory I'm gonna eat
this giant upside-down fish look at it
delicious it was great I can't believe
it
we've done it we beat Resident Evil who
knows everything this is all off the
books now nothing makes sense out our
country and that that note hittin your
life yep this is it lady
look I'm not say after after you just
you've been eating for a while you just
got away yeah why do you think cuz this
is this is the renegade Leon play
through these last couple of minutes
it's just going wild Oh God
we save right before this just go back
and load resident uh knieval won't open
it's probably good that it won't open
cuz I remember the puzzle and there's a
real doozy but it's okay because I think
I think we're I think we've done it so
Resident Evil on the switch piece
hang up there we go yeah res Eve on the
switch uh I think I'm gonna actually
pick it up I wasn't going to at first
because of the the $10 extra thing but
the fact I can play with a GameCube
controller again and the fact that it
seems to actually run pretty well
there's some obvious like frame hitches
and stuff but it's not not so much that
it makes me not want to get it so if you
want resevoir on the go hey this seems
like it's a pretty good setup or maybe
wait until it's a little bit discounters
because that $30 price tag is kind of a
thing but yeah yeah anything else do you
want to tell me what exactly but uh I
guess we'll see you guys then goodbye
everybody
Oh God all these buttons are all in
different places I don't know what's
going on alright that's not the button
this isn't the button this is the button
I'm just gonna do this
bye everybody